good morning it's tuesday so in addition
to our long-running collaboration here
on vlogbrothers we have
a podcast dear hank and john where we
answer listener questions provide
dubious advice and give people all the
week's news from both mars and
afc wimbledon making the podcast is one
of the highlights of my week because
it's two uninterrupted hours with my
brother and it has always been
so joyful until 46 days ago when someone
asked a question that burrowed into my
brain
and has refused to let me go a listener
named sarah wrote in to say that eight
years earlier when she was diagnosed
with asthma her doctor a licensed
physician
asked her how often she sneezed sarah
responded that she didn't sneeze that
much just a normal amount and then the
doctor said
sneezing is not normal i never sneeze
and then sarah went on to say that for
the last eight years every time she
sneezes
she thinks about this doctor who told
her that sneezing is not normal
and now having heard this story every
time i sneeze
i also think about this doctor in this
respect i am not alone because since the
podcast first aired i have heard from
hundreds of people who say that every
time they sneeze they think sneezing is
not normal i never sneeze
i suppose part of what makes this whole
thing so sticky in my mind is trying to
fathom
what this doctor thinks when they do
sneeze right like if you believe the
sentence i never sneeze how do you make
sense of the times when you do sneeze do
you pass it off as a fluke do you think
to yourself that wasn't a real sneeze
that was more of a
sneeze adjacent phenomenon or do you see
your sneezing as some sort of like moral
weakness or
character failing to be hidden from the
public and then part of the reason i
can't stop thinking about this hank is
because you named this person dr never
sneezer scrooge which is just such a
perfect joke how could i ever let that
leave my brain
but i think there's something else going
on too which is that ridiculous and
absurd and outrageous statements
just stay with me they penetrate in a
way that carefully considered nuance
statements
don't like if this doctor had said
sneezing can be one symptom of seasonal
allergies do you also experience a
stuffy nose
i wouldn't know about this doctor and i
certainly wouldn't think about them
every time i sneeze
and in our attention economy where the
mere act of capturing attention is on
some level valuable
saying i never sneeze is certainly gonna
capture more attention than like
being a good doctor similarly people who
say outrageous stuff online can
capture a lot of attention like if you
say that stalin was underrated or that
it isn't necessary to wash your lower
legs or that grease ii
is the canonical grease movie you will
get lodged inside of many people's minds
now you won't be thought of in primarily
a positive way but still there is
value to be found in saying the
stupidest possible things in the loudest
possible way which just to state the
obvious
is not a good way to organize an
attention economy but that to use some
doctor terms is a diagnosis
and not a treatment because i don't know
the treatment like how am i to free
myself from thinking sneezing is not
normal i never sneeze
every time i sneeze did i make the world
worse albeit in a very minor way by
sharing sarah's story of her ridiculous
sneeze-denying physician
am i making the world worse now by
sharing that story with more people via
a youtube video those aren't rhetorical
questions i don't know what to do about
the fact that what grabs my attention in
a crowded
information landscape is always going to
be what looks scary
or different or outrageous or ridiculous
i do realize this is a lot of weight to
put on sneezing isn't normal i never
sneeze but i
genuinely dislike the fact that some
random doctor saying something
ridiculous has reshaped my sneezing
experience forever
until quite recently i thought of the
internet and irl
as being fundamentally separate spaces
like when i was young
what i liked about the internet was
precisely that it was
not irl but in truth there is no bright
line between
real life and cyberspace and the
outrageous ridiculousnesses we
encounter whether online or off end up
shaping the people we
are and the world we share and i don't
know what to do about that
hank i'll see you on friday